even my aunt my great aunt told me she's
like no gina that guy's too handsome you
you don't want to date people
like they know they're good looking you
don't want your kids to have symmetrical
features
no way
so what we just have today people were
not attracted to right no thanks
[Music]
hello everyone welcome back to big mood
where are you where are you i'm so sorry
we're going to get a copyright strike
stop oh yeah exactly yeah we do yeah so
today obviously we have our regular crew
here it's me jess
oh me tiff
hi it's gina hi it's nikki it's nikki
i cannot dream tonight okay okay you
have to stop because otherwise this
whole episode
can we just stop and you bleep out here
karaoke break we need to carry on the
break
today i found um an article on buzzfeed
that pulled some stuff from reddit and i
thought it was a pretty interesting
topic it's not something we've really
ever done before and it's probably going
to piss people off
no no we're not hating on
this episode is people are sharing
things that are easier when you're
unattractive
so why i say it's gonna piss people off
is because they're gonna be like well
you're not unattractive so honey and
what makes you think that you can thank
you unless you compliment yourself and
then people will tell you you're ugly
and you shouldn't feel like you are yeah
it's usually men that tell us
but um so
i had to get i had to get a little sleep
get it in there
get in there real quick
so we've we've had super ugly duckling
feelings do you guys feel like yeah you
were ugly at some point in your life oh
yeah yeah dude so i think even though we
look cute on set right now and then
we're like so cute and you know like
don't judge from now like three out of
four of us are so cute today
i'll let you guys figure it out
yeah people are comments are like well i
think it's this and this person
imagine they're like it's eugene
if you think any of them are hot and i'm
the ugly one they were wearing my
clothes so yeah
i gave credit it's true oh [ __ ] that's
three out of the four that means i'm
but yeah so anyway this is uh just i
thought it'd be fun and funny or also
maybe eye opening a little bit like
maybe we don't realize things that are
either easier or harder for us just
based on our looks and you know i don't
know i thought it'd be interesting so i
like a challenge it is an interesting
choose attractiveness yeah yeah
it's funny like how sometimes people
come up with these reddit threads and
i'm like oh that's genius like yeah yeah
i would never thought of that so yeah
because usually you hear the opposite
where it's like of course you got that
promotion because you're so good looking
of course pretty perfectly pretty
privileged yeah so this is kind of the
opposite this is like the people
privilege the people writing in consider
themselves ugly i suppose okay yeah i
mean i don't know if anyone should ever
consider themselves to be ugly but i
guess there are some people physically
unattractively really maybe the world
has told them they are yeah there's a
subreddit called am i ugly
oh [ __ ] like straight up like they'll
post a picture and they're like i i
consent to criticism yeah that's like
the roast me one yeah but then these
people are actually giving you
constructive criticism it's like the hot
or not thing we used to have hot or not
yeah before dating sites yeah oh yeah
so yeah that wouldn't fly nowadays no
oh
i don't know what it i mean a lot of
things fly on reddit that wouldn't fly i
saw a tick tock where all the men in the
comments were getting pissed because
i think
um there's this girl she was being
recorded by some camera away in the back
like they were zooming in on her she was
on tinder swiping left so fast like oh
my god guys
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no and they got yourself a
physical first yeah of course that's
what dating apps are yeah and then men
in the comments are like she doesn't
even give a chance to look like she's
just sweating she's gonna be alone
forever it's like it doesn't take us
that long it doesn't take you that long
either to understand if you're attracted
to someone you know yeah
yeah they're like but they're so shallow
like really you want to talk about women
being shallow yeah yeah on a dating app
yeah we're the most forgiving yeah to
sexism by the time you're actually with
someone you're like a lot of times
people were like why is she with him
yeah exactly
okay
anyway it's very rare for me to see
someone say why is he with her yeah yeah
very rare
one million exactly
so guys were pissed in the comments like
she's not even giving it a chance she's
looking for 0.2 seconds i'm like
i don't know if you're slow it doesn't
take us that long
sorry
but okay especially in the culture of
just swiping like you're already your
brain is used to processing information
so quickly yeah and then um so i comment
to them like it doesn't take that long
you know that right and they're like
well
you guys are going to die alone because
you only go for looks like you do
realize that looks brings you in
like but it doesn't really keeps you
yeah it's round one of the interview
it's the initial attraction like i'm
sorry you're angry because deep down
said you know the initial attraction's
not there for you but don't project it
to everyone else true and work on
yourself instead get a haircut okay
what's easier for these people you don't
have to well just as an aside you don't
have to be someone like everyone's
someone yeah you just need to be one
person someone so why do you care that
you're like not everyone's someone
you don't have to be everyone someone
you know okay so um here we go on
so a reddit user asks what's easier when
you're unattractive and people answer
can we guess
you
can sure let's get one when we were ugly
well is more
easy for us in high school
i felt less judged i don't know i felt
like i could be quiet in the corner and
people wouldn't
like
like the less pressure being seen yeah
giving a [ __ ] because as an introvert
and if you have social anxiety like i
just don't like
i don't really like eyeballs on me
unless i i'm asking for it like when i
go perform on stage like i'm choosing
like i'm prepared to do that but like
walking into a
room making friends with girls
yeah oh yeah yeah
because then they're not worried about
you stealing their boyfriend yes yeah
like because the judgment is coming from
the girls not from the guys yeah uh
because like you just make friends and
stuff i was friends with a few of the
popular girls i was fine but then as i
grew older into my 20s i remember one
girl specifically saying
i'm gonna go hang out with these guys
and i'm like oh cool i want to go can i
come too and she's like
not can you not you're like a threat
yeah she's like can you not come like
why she goes because i'm like they're
going to give you more attention which
is like you know what you're
communicating that that's cool
but that that's shitty but also work on
yourself yeah work on yourself you know
love yourself a little bit more yeah
she's a friendship breakup because of
that yeah it's weird and she's like can
you like not
you know put on makeup or get dressed
i'm like
sure i guess i'm at your house what am i
gonna do
that's crazy and if you why would you
want to be with a guy that would easily
go for your friend if there was a any
other female in the room that's a good
point like is she gonna forever hygiena
yeah that's a lack of self so i was in
sweats and just hanging out and she we
were going to eat it i don't know like
wendy's or something and she dressed up
like she was going to a nightmare ma'am
this is why wow yeah i was like all
right this is weird i'm gonna be your
friend anymore that's extreme insecurity
yeah okay well we can go down this list
a little bit the first one that they
said was being single without being
questioned why oh oh so they said that i
guess they're family members or random
people they talk to you they never ask
them why are you still single but maybe
they feel like it's easier because they
don't have to [ __ ] like explain
themselves the pressure the pressure is
off when you're gonna get married
crazy huh wow do you consider that to be
something that bothers you like if did
someone ever ask you like why are you
still single gina like do you feel any
type of way about that not really i mean
i do get asked that yeah but i don't
really get bothered by it yeah because i
know why i'm single you know at the time
and it's just like
uh and it's not because you're insulting
yeah
it's definitely not it's just your
personality
you don't feel pressured because of it
you have been like you had dated and
stuff you had yeah people maybe these
are people that just are like never a
long time single and then more
attractive people if they're a long time
single then they'll get asked more
frequently or something
that's true
huh that whole thing of like asking why
someone's still single doesn't really
make sense if you think about it because
it's like everyone is on a different
life path like they've probably been in
a relationship and then got out of what
like so why is there like a why are you
single question like maybe they think
it's a compliment like you should be
with somebody oh yeah yeah like look at
how look at you you're a catch or it's
like what's wrong with you yeah why are
you still single
what's the real t
yeah
i feel that more yeah sometimes um like
there's people that i know like in their
40s 50s i can't hold down a relationship
for more than like two months and it's
like why are you still single and then
you get to know me like there it is
yeah that's true yeah i never thought
about it they yeah like we never ask our
ugly friends why they're still single i
just don't know
why i don't have any friends
so
i'm very strict i really i honestly
really don't have ugly friends i that i
can think of one of the four of us
[Laughter]
but okay let's try another one um what
else is not what else is easier being
ugly getting old this is the most
important example beauty is fleeting and
i see a mental health crisis with so
many people being able to unable to cope
with their aging and it's very yeah if
you put all your value into aesthetics
and beauty oh aging is going to be so
the desperation to stay young and yeah
i do know people like that you have me
too and then you see the desperation so
apparently and it's kind of sad yeah
hey it's okay let go
i remember reading a reddit post about
this woman who said like uh as i grew
older i noticed that men were hitting on
me less and less and yeah it took her a
while to like accept that but also
because men are pedos and they like
little [ __ ] 16 year olds
there's also people that were like for
example
joan rivers [ __ ] hot as [ __ ] like as
she got older she got hotter but like
when you look at her
i'm talking about yeah like when she got
hotter the dead one listen as she got
older she got hotter okay i'm trying to
think of like some examples but there's
some people where i'm like you weren't
oh jody
jodie foster jayla was always hot what
are you talking about so jody foster you
see her on freaky friday she's like this
like true nerdy looking freaking redhead
kid and then you see her now or like you
know as she grew up into her 30s and
you're like whoa well there's definite
examples of women who have aged
very well yeah
yeah yeah like well especially when you
have money so i'm saying that if you're
unattractive like there's not as much
pressure to maintain your beauty that's
true you have this low expectations and
then you just will supersede them
especially working you know i kind of
feel that way because i've worked in
entertainment for yeah [ __ ] more than
half my life
and
there are times where i said like if i
ever get
severely like my face gets get caught in
a meat grinder i wouldn't know what to
do like just i wouldn't know what to do
anymore because that is my career you
just want to get your brand so
you mean your face you 100
believe that all of your market value is
in your face not all okay but i know a
very strong big part of it is just that
you don't want to do the work that's
going to require having a job there
i already have plans for you
like you don't want to do anything that
doesn't require are you pretty i do
because eventually i'm going to retire
and just have money and properties and
[ __ ] like that but like if it were to
happen now yeah i'm [ __ ] because if
you do like a regular job if you would i
could but it won't be the amount what
kind of amount of weight if you lost
[ __ ] half your face you just do like
a robot cosplay [ __ ] like you wouldn't
make it
yeah you could just wear like a
really sexy mask because like your
body's still hot yeah exactly just don't
lose your personality you kind of
reminds me of that one tick tock in the
beginning a pandemic with that one girl
where she was like
wait my whole personality is looking hot
what the [ __ ] am i gonna do when half of
it is covered like oh nice interesting
oh no it was just it was a joke but it
was kind of serious yeah whatever it was
kind of a joke well we love a self-aware
queen yeah but she was just like
i'm mean like how am i gonna be nice to
people like what
she's kind of funny so yeah it's like um
if something were to happen i know
there's still going to be people like no
we still love you your personality's
cool but
in entertainment you're one
one of your top selling factors is the
way that you look yeah you just have to
rebrand though yeah
i feel like the industry has i mean it's
still definitely that a hundred percent
but it's not as
intense like as it was when we were kids
like that was like number one there was
like a cookie cutter standard of beauty
back then yeah whereas now like it's
cool to be like your own unique thing
yeah and i feel like you as a gamer can
totally make some sort of crazy cosplay
issues who is an example right now
that where that's actually working what
do you mean like really english is not
like uh like she's very pretty though i
know but she's not like this traditional
standard you know like her she's not
like to show off her body yeah she's not
showing off her body she's not like um
that being this this barbie chick she's
like in the 90s it was all pam anderson
or you're ugly i'm talking about like
severely mean yeah like because she's
you know the monkey
yeah
oh [ __ ] yeah
yeah i just feel like that's a story
like because you are already you before
you got made true so you can you already
have a following and then you can easily
rebrand you just have like a dope ass
[ __ ] like that would be like okay
okay christopher reeves still had a
following
after he's a man doesn't care
yeah that's true anyway okay how about
we try another one people assume your
successes are actually based on your
skills uh
i could see that that's a hard thing
well i think it's like if if i spent all
of this time right getting my cpa
license and getting a job at a really
good company people are just assuming
it's like oh
you got a free pass because you're
pretty you didn't really work that hard
or something like that you didn't have
to worry about [ __ ] in these comments
right now
but it's true yeah it is true like
pretty privileged does exist it does
yeah especially here in l.a well
definitely in l.a and also in any
client-facing industry so i do believe
that maybe i had a better chance
uh when i got my interview like when i
got the job like maybe just because i i
maybe fit the mold of what it looks like
what they want as a client-facing
individual so i believe that's true but
i think what this person's saying like
people assuming your successes are based
on your skills like that would bother me
if people really didn't think that i was
actually smart yeah enough to do the job
yeah and it was just because you look
like someone we could put in front of a
client there was an episode of modern
family where sofia vergara finally
confronts uh what's a blonde girl's name
oh yeah she's like the mom yeah and
she's like do you know how hard it is
for me like oh yeah being the pretty one
because all the mothers think i'm just
here to steal their husbands they'll be
treats me nicely like people just think
i'm a competition men don't treat me
seriously yeah and they just think that
i'm just this pretty thing that just
stands there
which i you know like i understand like
people want to be taken seriously for
things like women in gaming that's a
huge thing already it's like oh you're
only here because you're pretty yeah
people brand you as this one-dimensional
thing exactly it's like oh if you're
sexy you can't be anything else right
yeah like there's still you could still
develop a skill come on be intelligent
yeah with looks do you think that we
assume that like say we had an ugly
person i mean obviously i don't like
using these words but we had an ugly
person and a pretty person with the same
level of skill do you think that we
would believe the uglier person is
smarter
i don't know i felt like i
i felt like in comedy so when i was in
stand-up comedy i felt like it
you almost like were more accepted if
you were less attractive yeah i remember
like david saying that like yeah i found
a more funny when he was i would take my
i wouldn't wear makeup i would put my
hair up i would wear hoodies and like uh
jeans just because i just wanted to be
accepted like you don't want to
intimidate the females in the audience
and like also the other female comics
are just kind of judgy and and then you
don't want the guys to want to [ __ ] you
more than they think you're funny you
know yeah it's just a weird thing so
like in the places that i've worked um
yeah i've always been like man like yeah
that's
i do see uh like women that
were not traditionally
beauty um you know having an easier time
maybe making it in that industry it
takes away like an extra layer that they
have to worry about like being used for
sex or like not but then those women
would say oh the pretty women have an
easier time because they don't have to
be as funny they just talk about their
vagina yeah yeah
so i don't know yeah so that's actually
because i have seen comics too that are
like the traditional pretty especially
like in the early 2000s there was this
one that pops in my mind but i forgot
her name but she would always wear like
the cute like pretty doll kind of
dresses yeah i remember like blonde hair
kind of like really like she looked like
a barbie she was really pretty
and i'm trying to think i'm like was she
funny
i can't remember she had a good stick
yeah yeah that's actually what i i'm not
gonna lie i still battle with that at g4
because uh if anyone here has seen like
my streams at g4 i wear a lot less
revealing clothes
because
i almost like since the the video why
did you buy such huge tits i know right
yeah it suits my body yeah she wants the
option
that does get together
all right so if you guys watch my
streams i actually wear a lot more like
loose fitting clothes not any like i
have like no cleavage on their showing
at all yeah um and it's because i still
feel like the gaming industry is still
in its infancy when it comes to having
women in the industry being respected
yeah so
a part of me i battled myself every day
part of me is like i want to be seen for
my gaming the things that i know about
gaming my personality but also at the
same time i want to be who the [ __ ] i am
you know so it and that's the same thing
when i was streaming it's like i don't
really want to show a lot of cleavage
but it's like this is the clothes that i
like so i still battle with that every
single day in like a male dominated
industry yeah and speaking of clothes oh
that's where we got stitch fix here for
today's sponsor
yeah yeah so your style isn't one size
fits all it's about what suits your body
like what gina was talking about it's
like you know like what makes me feel
like me and everyone has
pace
so everyone has their own approach to
their style and also like what suits the
moment and so why not shop at a store
that is personalized for your size and
your style specifically
introducing stitch fix freestyle a shop
built just for you stitch fix freestyle
is your trusted style destination where
you can discover and instantly buy
curated items based on your style likes
and lifestyle so whether you're looking
for a brand that you love or you're
willing to try a new one at stitchfix
freestyle you can shop a range of over 1
000 brands personalized to your size and
fit with styles for workouts to work
wear for lounging around the house or
for a night out stitch fix freestyle has
clothes for any occasion plus there's no
subscription required and they offer
free shipping returns and exchanges so
get started today by filling out your
style quiz at stitchfix.com
mood that's stitchfix.com
mood to try stitch fix freestyle
stitchfix.com
mood and shop your looks yay
um and while you're taking care of your
wardrobe also take care of your mental
health
as the year ends another oh my god the
year is ending yeah already
uh another holiday season is upon us and
for many of us that means travel and
family
and that's really stressful because
plane tickets are expensive
who even wants to see their family
honestly
after this time
yeah that we love them
and family stuff is stressful because
like a lot of things get brought up
sometimes you don't have the best
relationship with your family and that's
true
it can bring up a lot of you know stuff
that you want to talk about but you
don't know who to talk about when you
have talk space so uh it says the season
to be jolly but sometimes it just
doesn't feel that way and that's okay
ease of the burdens the holidays can
bring with talkspace online therapy
talkspace is the number one online
therapy platform there are thousands of
licensed therapists available for you to
match with across dozens of specialties
including anxiety depression
relationships and more talkspace is
ready to help you start feeling better
with a single message talkspace works
around your schedule at your convenience
with live video sessions and unlimited
messages with your dedicated therapists
you can set goals with your therapist
and develop techniques to cope in
difficult times like the holidays
talkspace offers individual therapy
couples therapy and medication
prescription services
so if you need a little support to help
you through the end of the year or want
to start building towards a better
upcoming year talkspace is here to help
match with a licensed therapist when you
go to talkspace.com and get 100 off your
first month with the promo code mood
that's 100 hairs off when you use code
mood at talkspace.com
that's a lot of dolls
but yeah so like i was saying like it's
it's i fight with myself every morning
that i'm
um
getting dressed because i remember when
my first announcement that i got
announced at g4 came out someone
commented oh just another big breasted
bimbo using her looks to get into gaming
with her only fans my first of all [ __ ]
i don't have only fans
so annoying i should because i want to
make more money try playing you on video
games right exactly yeah and that's it's
i don't know when i'm going to reach
that point where i'm like [ __ ]
there's always going to be people
commenting that yeah they're just
they're very jealous also i mean at some
point you have to
be okay with the fact that like yes
pretty women sell entertainment and
there's nothing wrong with that exactly
so it doesn't also mean that you're not
good at your job yeah exactly so i kind
of worked hard to be there yeah
i kind of feel like
why am i hiding i should make it a point
that women that look like me or any
other woman can be in the industry but
the other hand it's like
i don't want to be seen just that way so
it's a weird thing it's also in like how
you talk and like how you let people
treat you too so it's like you can be
hot as [ __ ] but if someone crosses the
line and you allow it then you're kind
of like letting the stairs oh she's just
a [ __ ] bimbo like you know tell her
to suck my you know what i mean yeah so
like i i've started taking photos again
recently and someone commented like whoa
you know you're like crazy and funny in
g4 but never knew you had this
yeah underneath all that clothing you
know and it's like uh i kind of just
want to be myself now
yeah
i like that
it's it's yeah you have to balance those
things out with your in your own mind
it's like it's only you it's like right
it is just yeah and you need to be like
you know what no i'm going to own this
now yeah yeah yeah because even other
people's opinions you're letting them in
exactly it is really you it's i didn't
understand if i was doing a disservice
to women in the gaming industry
on both like
no matter what side i'm taking i think
what the way that you handle the job is
gonna matter more than if you're gonna
be hot or not and i think in the
entertainment industry you gotta just do
everything you can to stay there be in
there stay there and like have that
opportunity but like it's just it's
gonna be more in the way you conduct
yourself that's gonna be determine
whether or not you do a disservice to
other women yeah so i think just
whatever you wanna do on the outside
you're in the entertainment industry
like just do that mm-hmm
all right g4 i'm showing up next monday
with pasties
um i read another one um this person we
kind of touched on this one this person
said not having fake friends oh so
yeah do pretty people all just have fake
friends
no they don't like they don't all just
have fake friends but i was taught by
this girl that i knew back then when i
first started go dancing and she she was
pretty you know like she spent her whole
life not her whole life but you know she
was a little bit older than me and she's
pretty she was one of those like mary
rich kind of girls and she said straight
up she's like gina like
you can't you like you cannot have ugly
friends like not that you cannot but you
just be careful around them because
they're going to throw you on the bus
whenever they possibly can and that
brought me back to thinking about that
girl that told me hey don't come out
with us because
the guy's gonna get your attention oh
geez and i was like and when i first
heard i was like what the [ __ ] you mean
that's messed up like i just want to be
friends with people yeah she's like look
that's the truth a lot of times you know
like she's she's like i a lot of times
when i have friends that are deemed not
as attractive they start treating me
like [ __ ]
well so this person is jealous they say
that just being unattractive in general
means you have less fake friends
so it's kind of like the other way
around like they don't think about
competing if like if there's just like a
group of ugly ducklings or whatever oh
they're saying the opposite that it's
easier for them because they don't have
to compete i mean i don't know like i
guess do pretty people only want to hang
out with pretty people i mean i guess
we've seen we've seen a little bit of
that right like
for clout i guess maybe like you have
pretty fairy in their photos yeah oh
yeah so maybe for the experience like
what gina's friend was saying like that
would make sense if that is a thing
because then they they might have had
bad experiences with
less attractive people trying to tear
them down because of jealousy or
whatever so then pretty people are like
let me just have only pretty friends
yeah i don't know that could be an
experience but then also like the whole
group photo thing i know there are
people like i have heard of that be a
thing where they just want attractive
people in the photo but then i've also
heard the opposite thing where it's like
they want less attractive people
i have literally never thought of never
happiness of my friends
i don't think i yeah it's i care more
about who they are and how i feel around
them just like dating i guess like i i
don't have a physical type like i don't
like
i've never like just thought someone was
like oh my god like i have a crush on
them based on their physical appearance
they have to carry themselves a certain
way they just have a certain type of
personality yeah and then they're
instantly cute to me i don't care what
they actually look like that's so
accurate yeah and so i feel like that's
how it is with friends it's like i
i feel you on a soul level first and
then like actually i didn't even notice
like i remember being in high school and
like towards like the tail end of high
school
and i had a friend
that i didn't even know that like other
people found her unattractive yeah
until someone mentioned it and i was
like what are you talking about like
that's just wait what yeah i was so
[ __ ] mind blown i was like i've
literally never seen that like she's
beautiful to me because i know who she
is like yeah inside like
i don't know it sounds really weird to
not notice something so obvious
especially for like physical
attractiveness
but there's every day there's a point in
your youth where you you start to
realize like oh popularity is a thing
and like oh we're starting to split off
now because like when we're kids right
we're just all playing in the playground
not giving a [ __ ] but then at some point
the physical thing comes in and
everyone's like oh this is going to be a
popular person because they're pretty
and this is going to be a not popular
person because they're quote unquote
ugly or something so
i guess you probably kind of hit that
point maybe a little bit later
in life where you're like oh i guess it
does matter like everyone's kind of
looking at me and like who i'm with and
if i'm with like an ugly friend then
they're they're gonna look down on me
yeah or something huh i never had that i
always had a problem even having friends
so
yeah like i think i just like um i just
never noticed i mean i obviously was
never gonna be the popular one and like
i could see who was the popular one also
the popular girl in elementary school
hated me so she made sure no one would
be my friend yeah um and then when we
went to junior high it was like i made
friends with people in my like
church camp or whatever like but they
weren't like friends friends we just
like knew each other through a hobby
or like a thing and then in high school
it was like i just made friends with the
other outcasts yeah i was always like
outcasted i was like poor dirt poor
pale as [ __ ] freckles and like you know
like everyone was just like who was like
what is this [ __ ] creature you know
so like i was never
making friends based on how pretty i was
like will you accept me
yeah so i don't know i yeah i can't even
imagine now like i'm trying to think
back like did i think like when i felt
like an ugly person did i feel like all
the pretty people were fake friends with
each other because that's such a weird
i'm just trying to get to like what this
person's thinking like they think that
because they're unattractive they don't
have fake friends hmm so where does that
come from i don't know you know yeah
yeah that's it's uh like instagram
people are like just friends because
they look good on you but that's more
about that's even less about
attractiveness and how than it is about
how famous you are how connected you are
how rich you are
yeah yeah i would think that
dating would be
easier maybe because like there was
another one in here that's talking about
how guys um like not yeah so knowing
which men are bad people i have a really
attractive friends who men will put
they'll put on a whole show and a brand
new angelic personality for but i see
right away how they actually treat women
they don't want to bang you're not a
good person if you're only good to
people you want something from so maybe
like in dating
that would be yeah way harder if no one
thinks that like oh the pretty people
they get everyone that they want but
also they get just a lot of sickness
yeah [ __ ] yeah that's true i was we
were just watching [ __ ] boy island yeah
we did watch the first two episodes yeah
i was like i never would have guessed
that one was a [ __ ] boy yeah
what is it about or what so there's half
of them are [ __ ] boys and half of them
are nice guys and then the girls like
eliminate
people as it as it goes
yeah like are they playing a role or
they're like they're dating
it's like a dating
yeah so there's this one guy who's
actually like one of the ugliest ones on
the show and has the biggest [ __ ] ego
person yeah but he's just like yeah i'm
the king of the [ __ ] boys and all this
stuff and he's like talking to this girl
on a boat about like how he was adopted
and his sister
and i'm just sitting there watching it
like
these [ __ ] boys are putting on so fake
like they're laying it on so thick but
also in a way that seems so casual and
genuine and then for them to cut to the
next shot of the guy being like yeah
it's all [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm just like
oh that's insane she's like because
they're trying to get into these hot
girls pants yeah and they're on tv and
they're on tv yeah but so for sure
putting it up the producers are like
yeah more and more no but i think guys
are really like they are and the guys
they'll have these stupid little um like
slides or whatever they'll be like yeah
if i had to choose love or money 100
every time it'd be money you know and
i'm just like then why are you trying so
hard with this girl like just let her
know like yeah i'm just i'm down to [ __ ]
like what why make this whole [ __ ]
story and like [ __ ] mess her because
he wants to win like i know it just
drives me [ __ ] people do that in real
life too it's not even just for money on
the show yeah
i could see the motivation behind that
though it could be like you know like
they were [ __ ] over by some pretty
girl or like that specific guy like he
was [ __ ] over by some pretty girl and
now he's out to just yeah [ __ ] tear
down these girls as like conquer
they they conquered them yeah they're
trophies
stinson from uh how i met your mother oh
like that's his whole thing too because
he got [ __ ] over so he's like let me
[ __ ] screw every girl possible and
i'm gonna feel like a king and it's like
oh you're so empty inside yeah i saw the
sick talk of a man who's bitching about
how women wear makeup and it's
disgusting and a few videos down it's
also i'm saying i was married to a woman
who loved wearing makeup there we go and
she
did terrible things to me i'm like oh
there it is yeah that's a you issue dude
that has nothing to do with women's
makeup that's a really weird thing to
latch onto makeup all
probably how you tricked right with all
the makeups yeah you're stupid do you
really think my eyelids are sparkly all
the time
like you're dumb
it's not my problem
it's my ice blue eyeshadow i don't know
so i would definitely argue that um
dating and love is probably harder for
the more attractive people yeah um
especially like the absolute tens
because then like you never know like
people are just trying to get it
absolute tense and they'll probably do
anything or say anything or even
[ __ ] them over yeah
that's probably why
you might see
them be with significantly less
attractive people because maybe they're
more genuine because they're like oh
there's no way i'm gonna get you let me
just be myself
and then there's that study that said
women are more happy when they're dating
someone
that is less
better looking
really because they're less than worried
about them cheating or something that's
yeah insecure that's it
down for that because like i'm not gonna
[ __ ] date some [ __ ] ugly person
just to feel better yeah the you know
it's like what why do we have like like
have to date so far down in order to be
happy like that's [ __ ] that no i'll just
be by myself even my aunt my great aunt
told me she's like no gina that guy's
too handsome you you don't want to date
people
like they know they're good looking you
don't want your kids to have symmetrical
features
no way
so we just have some day people we're
not attracted to right no things i think
everyone's attracted to something
different like don't i don't know
like i guess
i just wouldn't be
i wouldn't be thrown by that because
like that just because they're
aesthetically pleasing doesn't mean they
have quality yeah you know so and if
they do have quality then they're not
going to cheat on you like they're not
yeah you know like so yeah that's the
point people are like lower your
standards date an ugly guy he won't
cheat on you that's [ __ ] oh yeah i
can tell you for sure exactly i've dated
several ugly [ __ ] and they may
have treated me like they're more
insecure yeah yeah i should make a shirt
that says ugly people cheat too yes yeah
it really has to be based on your next
character
and i could be considered maybe like a
seven or an eight so like closer towards
the higher end of the scale right i
wouldn't [ __ ] and cheat on someone like
i wouldn't [ __ ] really like that's
like why don't they're a good person
someone else always would you know
that's [ __ ] up so this one i guess
kind of the same thing this person said
this may be unpopular but
everyone who has a happy love life i
know is unattractive
beauty attracts people thanks a lot
it's like money not that ugly it's like
money real love and happiness are not
related to money or beauty
so i don't like these because it's so
it's casting such a general blanket over
like like if you're pretty everything is
fake everything is false it's never real
it's never good yeah and earn it yeah
there's one couple that i'm like they
are so and they've been in love since
like they were they met in college and
they're both almost like 40 now and they
are very attractive they all look they
both look really young for their age and
they're they're great like i don't
i don't think that's a metric for hmm
that's weird that's just a that's just a
anecdotal inflating like
that every person who's attractive is
also fake and superficial yeah there are
a lot of them right because they've had
their life handed to them they get
things easier but i know ugly people in
bad relationships too yeah
i don't know what that means but yeah i
guess it comes down to i'm trying to
figure out how they're thinking so
may ah damn it they really if we're
together and we're ugly then i don't
have to worry about you cheating because
like essentially
people cheat yeah
but then like the ugliest people i know
have been the biggest shooters so the
amount of people that
hit on you is less so there's less of a
chance is is that what they're getting
because they're like if you both based
your relationship off of superficial
reasons yeah yeah that's why you're
going to get together because you have
abs and you have tits right if that's
the only reason we act together then
yeah that's not a real it's so
one-dimensional but that's just so
that's not very common that's the
assumption that everyone who's pretty
would do that but they they have a lot
of options if that person's in high
school maybe this is true yeah but like
i feel like once you're an adult adult
like i don't i don't see that there's
like not an 18 year old adult yeah yeah
actual adult yeah
once you've bought a house
yeah just kidding not everyone can reach
that but yeah something like
significantly like you're not still a
little kid yeah like you're paying your
bills you're working you're doing things
like you're
having a life in society
well maybe hollywood doesn't help that
because it seems like actors they get
together they're on a movie they're hot
so that's not difficult because that's
just like that's just a workplace
romance you know like you do get
attracted to the people that you're
spending the most time with you know and
i mean like steve and i met through work
through being on sketches together and
it wasn't because i thought he was like
the hottest person i've ever seen is
just because i i love working with him
and then our personalities like matched
and i could i knew i'd have a blast with
him as a partner but then most of the
hollywood marriages right or like
they'll it's just it's it lasts like a
cycle it's like a year or two year
cycles
in a movie and then they they date the
next hot person and so i guess maybe
regular people
think that that's how all hot people are
yeah you think like media makes us think
that way possibly i mean or if you're
like i know a lot of like in the wealthy
culture like it's very
like image is really important yeah and
so
like keeping up an image and marrying
another wealthy person who looks
attractive and then like making it look
like you have like the best most perfect
life is very important but that's more
like a a rich stereotype i feel like
than a attractive stereotype yeah
well one thing that you don't have to
maybe be physically attracted for for
because they won't actually see you but
they'll just hear your voice
dipsy everyone needs an escape but those
can be hard to come by right now enter
dipsy let yourself get lost in a world
where good things happen and where your
pleasure is the only priority
oh my god i'd be so good at this you're
already really good
i can only get so erect mickey thank you
dipsy is an audio
so it's an audio app with sexy stories
designed to turn you on so you pick like
pick your little kink you know hear a
story in that kink and i used to go to a
site before we had dipsy that like you
could only read stories now you can
actually hear the stories being read to
you and you can pick your type okay
each dipsy audio story features
characters that feel like real people
and immersive scenarios so you feel like
you're right there okay so if you have a
crush on someone in the workplace
you could feel like you're right there
next to them okay they release new
content every week so there's always
more to explore no matter who you're
into or what turns you on who or what
turns you on
we don't need to know and if you need to
wind down dipsy also has wellness
sessions sensual bedtime stories and
soundscapes to help you relax before you
drift off for our listeners dipsy is
offering an extended 30-day free trial
when you go to dipsystories.com
mood that's 30 days of full access for
free when you go to d-i-p-s-e-a
stories dot com slash mood dipsy stories
dot com slash mood
yeah so if you got poop on any part of
your body would you just wipe it off or
would you wash it off i like to wash it
a lot of parts of my body
excuse me
this isn't the dipsy ad anymore
let's talk about the gift that keeps on
giving the hello tushy bidet
it cleans your butt way better than
wiping cuts your toilet paper use down
by 80 percent saves trees and all the
thousands of gallons of water used to
convert them into toilet paper and it
comes with a book full of poop jokes
my butt is in love i feel like the bidet
is a lifesaver when you're on your
period what's better than getting a nice
fresh
water splash
in between all day long we love it
nothing also
when you poop and you're on your period
it gets really disgusting so wash it off
with water your beautiful creatures the
hello tushy is uh the best thing to
happen in my bathroom in a long time
stop spreading your business around your
butthole with toilet paper start washing
with hello tushy the hella tissue bidet
washes your bum with fresh water for a
way better clean than toilet paper
simply spray and pat it dry it attaches
to your existing toilet no electrician
or plumber is needed it installs in less
than eight minutes cuts down your toilet
paper used by 80 save money and paper
waste join the millions of hello tushy
happy customers right now who take care
of their yule logs the dignified way
give the gift of a clean bum to yourself
or your loved ones this holiday season
and get ten percent off plus free
shipping right now at hellotushy.com big
mood that's hellotushy.com big mood for
10 off and free shipping alrighty well
there i mean some of these other answers
were kind of like being left alone being
unbothered if i'm in a baggy hoodie with
the hood up and sweatpants no one
bothers me at a bus stop if i have a
dress on and look cute seven times out
of ten people get too close or start
chatting my solution is pretending i
don't speak english that's what i was
basically just being left alone no like
going to auditions so the type of
auditions i was getting sent out for
were like
um the hot girl at the bar hot girl at
the nightclub like wait hot waitress or
whatever you have to wear like dresses
like you have to dress as the character
right but you have to park downtown like
where there's you have to walk past like
so many people yeah you're wearing heels
and i just don't i don't do that in the
middle of the day and i don't like it
yeah because people follow you they
really do they'll follow you to your car
i had a pepper spray on me and i also
lived in the middle of hollywood and um
i would so i'd come home and if i'm
walking i would walk to my acting class
and i would walk back but i would have
to make sure because when i walked back
it was night time that i was wearing
like sweatpants hoodie like look as much
like a dude as possible
because people do follow you home yeah
you know when i was younger uh like in
my 20s when everything matters a little
bit more i got
really nervous and like anxious and i
would get kind of sad and i'm like i
can't believe one day i'm gonna be old
and ugly right like it scared me so much
like it would give me anxiety sometimes
i'm like oh my god i can't believe that
i'm gonna actually be ugly like i look
at my mom and like my aunties and stuff
and i'm like they're ugly now like their
bodies don't look good anymore like how
like how am i gonna cope being ugly
and then it's funny because like i'm
getting older now and like i'm getting
more wrinkles and like my body's not in
the best shape as it was like you know
10 years ago and stuff and i'm like
it actually does feel like less pressure
yeah it's like it's almost like as you
age you become okay
it's actually more comfortable like not
caring so much and it's funny how like
you think that
being ugly is the worst thing to ever
happen to you
when really it's not i mean obviously it
would be difficult for your career i'm
going to kill myself yeah the moment i
get a single wrinkle
but like really just living life without
that external pressure yeah is like
really great so i mean i guess that's
part of the aging where you're like oh
wait actually that's what i've always
said i loved about my 30s because i felt
like i've always been a mid-30s cat lady
and when i was in my 20s my young 20s
they put all these expectations on me to
like want to dress up and go to the club
and like look a certain way and be this
weight and like this like wear these
clothes and i don't i've never related
to that lifestyle at all and i would
always make excuses that i was like sick
i would call in sick to going out like
basically
so sorry
i'm not cough i can't i'm just cold i'm
too cold i can't wear a dress
i think like being um
[Music]
i don't know sometimes
it's easy to say that right like when
you still kind of have some of your
youth in your beauty and you're like oh
i don't really care about it or whatever
but then at the same time i'm kind of
like man if i really like i care i want
to take care of myself but if i really
got my face like ripped off or something
then i feel like i would probably feel
even better because like i'm not
inviting anyone to like slash my face or
anything like just because you know like
when the pressure's off
it's just amazing yeah i like i don't
think i'd like that because i don't like
change so like i'm okay with slow change
yeah you know aging is okay because i've
gotten used to like my face evolving
over time yeah but if it was just
suddenly like i'm 70 years old
i i don't like not being able to
recognize myself in the mirror so yeah
that like slow that's something
or like i guess for you just because
you're talking a lot about the pressure
is it mainly like pressure you put on
yourself or a pressure that you feel
like outside pressure society pressure
um i don't know it's probably a
combination of both
i'm not sure really
because i'm trying to analyze how i feel
about myself yeah like my
like my appearance and
now that i'm pregnant and i've been
gaining gaining weight and i see myself
like really getting more rounder like
than what i used to be and also like in
my genetics like a lot of like in my
family like a lot of my family once they
hit a certain age then they just become
like circles so like just really like
round faces round features
now that i feel
like i'm
inching towards that then i realize like
oh my gosh i'm getting older like it is
hard for me to let go and it's hard for
me to accept it and be like okay but
then also be
kind with myself because i'm pregnant
it's like hello of course you're gonna
gain weight like chill but
the fact that i am gaining weight in my
i look in the mirror and i'd see a
different face
that kind of freaks me out a little bit
yeah i'm like whoa i'm not this is an
identity thing like you're used to
seeing a certain thing like this is me i
can recognize who i am and stuff and i i
value that and then
like you're changing rapidly and you're
like oh no like yeah you're just getting
really fast because the pregnant cycle
happens but i mean obviously you know
the weight is going to come off after
you have the baby yeah that's i mean i
i hope
yeah well it's it's based on your
actions though like yeah
unless you have a medical issue then
you're it's just on you to get back to
the weight yeah and that's the thing
that scares me is because because of the
fact that it is in my genes to not be
super fit later on also like because of
my pregnancy right now there's like
there's a microscope on my thyroid and
how it's yeah it's operating right now
so i don't know what like what can
happen my thyroid could that's true
could [ __ ] up later on in this pregnancy
and then next thing i know i have uh
they call it hashimoto's or something so
like i'll it'll be easier for me to pack
on more weight and so i'm just like
ah hold on this is like this is not me
anymore like what's and i can't do
anything or i can try to help it but
like ultimately though it's kind of out
of my hands and then i'm thinking about
it i'm like is it a societal thing like
i i just feel ugly because i'm i have
the pressures of needing to look a
certain yeah absolutely it is yeah i'm
like yeah that's for sure part of it but
i feel like the majority of it though
it's like my own yeah i mean i don't
think anyone like wants to be
like either super overweight or feel
super unattractive i mean i don't think
that's like anyone's first choice like
in the world if we could choose so it's
probably internal too like because you
just like nice things you just like
feeling fit you just like feeling pretty
right yeah like it's getting me um
like i noticed that i do feel
down when i'm putting on my clothes
and they don't fit me anymore yeah and
i'm like oh man but then like i said i'm
not really giving i'm not allowing that
that gentleness for myself to be like oh
it's okay you're creating life like
you're pregnant yeah i think probably
every pregnant person is probably
freaking out yeah when that happens for
sure yeah i remember when i had sibo and
i was i gained um 20 pounds in a year
and like it's like i was eating
a strict diet exercising like crazy
eating like grapefruit and it wasn't
like well like it wasn't nothing was
helping and people just eat less than
you or just uh work out more yeah more
calories than you consume and i'm like
it's not that [ __ ] like i'm doing all
the blood tests everyone's like it's
normal and i remember like just wishing
i would get pregnant so i could have
something to blame it on because i was
like i wasn't used to this rapid weight
gain and i didn't know what the [ __ ] was
wrong with me but the doctors were like
you're perfectly normal except for
gaining that much weight isn't normal so
watch your diet i'm like my diet is so
[ __ ] clean like i was so strict
that was crazy
that way yeah i actually felt like that
before getting pregnant i'm like damn
i'm getting older i'm gaining weight
like i i obviously don't do anything to
help it either i'm not like super
working out or eating super clean so
obviously that's on me but i did feel
like man i kind of just want to get
pregnant at least i'll have an excuse
but also very pandemic so like no one
was able to really go out and do stuff
like because you before the pandemic you
were like going to all those fitness
classes yeah i was actually killing i
think that that's made a big difference
for me too and my fitness was like i i'm
not in the gym or surrounded by a bunch
of people breathing heavy so like i'm
not i don't think it's age it's really
lifestyle for me
and i think that's probably you'll
you'll bounce back get your baby you'll
get back in your class you'll be fine
i think you'll be okay
um
so some of the last ones they kind of
all seem like the same kind of like this
guy well this one is like a guy saying
like he's been faithful to his wife
because no one wants to hit on him and
this other person oh my god if he was
attractive he would cheat on his wife oh
you need to sound like a piece of [ __ ]
yeah this [ __ ] is this is what i'm
getting annoyed at is that it's like oh
well at least at least because i'm ugly
i don't have to worry about cheating
it's like no that doesn't these are just
stereotypes it's almost like people that
are like well if i can't be attractive
at least i have these things going for
me that those people can't have and i'm
like
there are shitty people on both ends of
the spectrum it's like they're they're
projecting an image i guess that's the
whole point of this reddit question
though yeah it is to really look at it
from that perspective
and and then that's why it was so
fascinating to me to hear that because
i'm like oh yeah no one really
thinks about that perspective no one
really talks about that perspective or
that experience that people that
identify themselves as less attractive
that they end up having so it was a
really intriguing question but i agree
like it is a little bit annoying hearing
the answers but i don't know maybe it's
because we already know that there are
unattractive people that
do the opposite of what they're saying
or very attractive people that don't
have
whatever they're saying so yeah
obviously it's not like
everyone's this way and i don't i don't
know if that's really what they're
intending with answering either probably
it's just more like maybe like what do
you think you have easily yeah because
you're the only one i agree with is the
one about intelligence because i when i
was all ugly duckling like going through
school and i was always top of the gate
classes like um top testing scores like
the 99th percentile and nobody autistic
nobody questioned it
because it wasn't like it wasn't pretty
unpopular okay nobody was like wait you
yeah you know but then when i talked
about it later like after going through
dude acting is all about like in the
beginning they're like it's all about
image like you have to go to like an
image consultant and they're all they
all made me lose 15 pounds immediately
when i got here and like go through like
an image consulting class go shopping
it was such a thing because you're
getting cast you have to get typecast
first and so they're like well you're
going to go out as this role but you
don't quite look it yet so you have to
go like work out with a personal trainer
make sure you have your skin as clear as
[ __ ] like
so it was a whole makeover and i did get
treated completely different because i
was getting cast a lot for like like the
oh my god like do you know where the
bathroom is because like my boyfriend is
gone for this weekend or whatever like
that kind of girl
and then i'm so good at it
he always like tells me where it is i'm
so drunk right now
that's funny and then so people would
see that and i was getting like i had a
lot of youtube videos i was part of a
sketch group and they'd always typecast
me in that role and then i that those
would get like hundreds of millions of
views and then people started knowing me
as that character and then i'd be in an
event and i noticed especially with guys
they would talk down to me like they'd
be like
oh i s oh my gosh i saw your video
it was really funny oh my god i'm a
[ __ ] child like thanks cool and they
completely different like i'm just not
used to getting talked to like that and
i had to get used to it and then i
started just playing that character just
because i was like well [ __ ] it if they
already think i'm dumb i'm just gonna be
that character and steve thought for the
longest time i was a [ __ ] dumbass
bimbo and then still does yeah yeah yeah
but now like when he
he said a couple of times on like video
and i told him not to say this but he
he's like i call you a genius all the
time like don't [ __ ] say that don't
like put that on me ricky bobby
but he's like no but you're so smart and
like people should know i'm like
it doesn't matter if you're smart you
don't have to go yelling from the
rooftops how smart you are but it is
annoying that people just automatically
assume like you can't handle that yeah
you know or like
that's why i kind of like poker because
like it's like you can't fake that like
you have to learn the technical skills
yeah and stuff so when you
win people are like oh [ __ ] like i
judged you wrong yeah well i do think a
lot of these responses are definitely
kind of um
maybe not entirely rooted in the truth
and also maybe a little resentful but
since i'm not
at the top level of attractiveness like
at the at the 10 level of attractiveness
i
do think those that i feel some of these
things sometimes too like i can kind of
see where they're coming from yeah
because like maybe if i'm not on a level
two
looking at the sevens and tens but maybe
if i'm at like a six or seven or an
eight looking at the tens that you know
what i mean like i i still feel like
some of that like do you i mean do you
ever look at like the hottest
[ __ ] and be like
[ __ ] dumb like no no no never i like
a lot of them are really smart yeah i
mean at least in the entertainment
industry because you have to
like know your [ __ ] you have to be a
shark with business and with aesthetics
to be maybe it's just like when we watch
reality tv really tv's are completely
different that's different like people
who are actually doing something that
does take a lot of intelligence but when
you watch reality tv do you really think
those people are top 10 attractive
because i don't think they're 10 out of
10 not everyone in the cr in the cast
will be but there will be some reality
in so long like a a lot of the 10 out of
10's they're actually getting real
real work like in the industry like
these are people that are like the
hottest in their hometowns type of thing
for me it's not about intelligence when
i see someone that's like a 10. for me
it's about them uh being kind or not
yeah true i always think for some reason
i'm like programmed to think that really
beautiful attractive people are mean and
when they're not i'm like so shocked
yeah what or like i immediately assume i
will say i do have a bias where i assume
that they're not going to be into the
same things as me like they're not going
to have the same interests
because i like i'm like oh well nobody
in the fields that i've been interested
in
like look like that yeah you know you
probably just like boats and golf and
stuff like i don't like yeah hot people
do i don't know
i still get the uh oh you don't look
like a gamer you're using nerd stuff
yeah dude i'm sorry i'm not wearing my
thick-ass glasses you know like it's i i
can kind of still see that like i
remember dating a guy it was like you're
really attractive kind of a fat boy
like meathead and then he turned out to
be a giant nerd i was like and then i
found myself realizing oh yeah i
shouldn't just assume like you know just
because of what they look like i know i
thought i was going to marry a nerd but
he's like all into sports oh whatever
crypto nerd he's definitely nerdy
i think rule of thumb you just shouldn't
just to get to know people first like
you just shouldn't judge anything based
off of looks you don't know anyone's
story you don't know what they've done
but you shouldn't [ __ ] on them when it
comes to dating if they don't find you
attractive right off the bat like i was
talking about earlier
earlier yeah yeah you can get to know
people whatever but don't get mad at
people just because they're not
attracted to you
like the initial attraction is not there
yeah don't be a butthole about it
especially if you're not going to do
anything about it you know so i don't
understand why girls don't talk to me
like dude you showered like last month
and you're
you're offended that women aren't
talking to you or the other way around
also you know well i mean society does
run on rules right like people that are
more attractive have less that's human
nature
is real so i don't want to just
ultimately say like don't care about
looks because it's like it is real
someone who's super ugly is going to
have a harder time if an attractive
person ever told you they never ever use
their looks to get something they're a
dirty [ __ ] liar or they're just not
aware they're not aware that yeah it's
just like a white privilege right like
i'm not aware that all of this was
easier or like that i didn't have those
problems because of it right so it's a
it's a thing but i think
we should definitely it's hard to
because with social media and society in
the way it is like it's almost that
looks are more important and more
important and more important it feels
like even for younger and younger and
younger kids i feel bad for this
generation
no i feel like this generation they're
actually kind of doing the right thing
they're moving towards kind of the right
thing because
gen z is crazy when it comes to like
body positive oh that's just positive
and stuff and accepting more body types
but then look at the people that that go
straight to the top of popularity though
it's all those
bimbo boys with their little hair but in
the beginning
but the shelf life isn't there yeah they
don't stay forever because i've been
through a lot of youtube generations
yeah and there's always like uh a new
the new fresh up-and-comer they're so
cute like young 20s people and then
they're there for two years unless they
actually have a skill to back it up
they're two years tops yeah but i do
think now gen z is actually handling it
pretty well when it comes they might go
a little bit crazy
i mean i didn't go kind of crazy i think
i i worry for them too because they're
the generation are growing up with
nothing but filters and like they're
only seeing it out like that like let me
see because then i also think about it
for my own teenager at home like
he really does emphasize on his own
looks and makeup tutorials like from
asia yeah exactly but they're like what
they're dressed like what the haircuts
are and like they really do care about
it just like in our generation so i'm
like i don't feel like more than our
generation because we yeah well we look
busted as [ __ ] that's so true
we didn't have to like we didn't post
ourselves and put ourselves out there
for
strangers to see and judge us and
comment on us and so if anything yeah i
feel like it's probably worse it's worse
it's it is definitely a worse hill to
climb but they are combating it more
than we had in our generation they're
more aware of like people's behavior at
least like we would let all kinds of
[ __ ] fly yeah like we never gave two
[ __ ] thoughts to like people being
shitty people and so they're at least
balancing that out i guess yeah i
remember reading a quote like gen z will
survive on coffee and adderall and punch
a cop in the face and go to
riots and stuff but they still have
trouble
making their own doctor's appointments
and it's the funniest goddamn thing ever
yeah the kids are all right guys okay
it's gonna feel they're all right
i don't know the world's gonna explode
but i think the kids are gonna be all
right it's gonna be all right well thank
you so much for listening today um if
you're ugly let us know in the comments
that you've had an easier time with and
all you attractive people shut the [ __ ]
up okay let them speak let them have a
voice
they're gonna say that about us
we're the only comments in there
yeah like you're the one of us yeah
all right
[Music]
all people are just wanting to be
accepted when you realize we're more the
same than different
then then you'll maybe understand the
world all right ted talk
we accept you the way you are except if
you're a furry if you're fur you get the
hell out of here we don't like your top
you're not supposed to yuck anyone's
young yeah yep and you're yelling okay
i'm okay with you
but is there a voyeurism for furries
because i think i'd be voyeuristic for
just specifically furries
i'm curious on how it works
well there's something true
i'm curious i'm curious i'm very sweaty
and itchy it doesn't turn me on i just
want to see how you guys are maneuvered
yeah i just need to know like an
experiment yeah like a nevermind yeah
sorry all right